martin biron c'était fanny grammont
christian dufour bonsoir bonsoir tu mens
ça on va revenir sur le budget d'abord
beaucoup d'ébullition aujourd'hui à
québec martin là dessus je veux faire
entendre l'opposition qui en a contre ce
500 de la qui est donné si je vais
résumer à trop de monde et pas
uniquement aux gens qui en aurait
vraiment besoin vous avez écrit là tu
stéphanie aujourd'hui et monsieur
legault qui répondent qu'ils ont fait
il ya toute une génération aujourd'hui
qui ne sait pas s'il va être capable un
jour de s'acheter une maison j'avais des
propositions concrètes qu'on en avait
fait bonifier leur à doubler les crédits
d'impôt à l'achat d'une première maison
s'assurer qu'on encadre et les flip rien
de tout ça ne se trouve dans le budget
pourquoi le premier ministre a laissé
tomber cette génération sais pas c'est
quoi vivre avec un salaire normal
son chèque de 500 à pia c'est une pièce
et 37 par jour ça paye pas les hausses
de loyer abusives plus en plus avec
l'extrait de l'augmentation
d'hydro-québec le mois prochain c'est
même pas assez pour s'acheter un café
chez tim hortons en quoi de donner 1000
$ à deux personnes qui vivent à côté et
qui gagne 5000 $ et une mesure équitable
pour les québécois
je pense que trop souvent on oublie la
classe moyenne je sais pas vrai que les
gens qui gagnent plus de quarante ou
cinquante mille dollars par année ont
pas été affectée par une inflation star
chaque québécois de décider ce qu'ils
font avec cet argent là plutôt que de
les tenir par la main
alors martine ses revenus on a parlé
hier
ses revenus et madame anglais qui par
ailleurs effectivement dit on aurait
voulu voir d'autres mesures pour l'aide
au logement mais c'est un paria mais sur
les cinq ça c'était prévisible ouais bah
en fait honnêtement à les partis
d'opposition étaient tous sur le même
pied sur la question du budget autant
sur les mesures qui auraient voulu voir
plus large sur notamment le logement ou
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre mais sur le
500 $ ou 6 il estimait que c'était trop
que c'était beaucoup pour des gens qui
étaient en moyenne cela dit il est
patent de revenu familial de 200 milles
c'est cette portion langues sont quand
même assez rare c'est à la baisse mais
monsieur legault c'est ce pour plusieurs
raisons la d'abord c'est sûr que il
combat l'inflation en même temps il
envoie un petit cadeau à cet électorat
là la classe moyenne 1 35 45 1 familiale
qui a cliqué vraiment exaspérés par les
mesures sanitaires vont gérer au micro
et qui commence à regarder du côté des
conservateurs alors ce une mesure a su à
droite et sa paresse c'est c'est quand
même assez habile ça va faire un effet à
court terme monsieur legault va pouvoir
continuer là débat mettre de l'avant de
nouvelles mesures
stéphanie vous avez écrit là-dessus
j'ai même si tu es plus du plan si
j'allais à gérer les c'est sûr que c'est
ainsi un clin d'oeil avec un sourire
mais oui c'est vrai qu'à l'époque de
duplessis on achetait des élections avec
des bouts de route moi je dis pas qu'on
essaie d'acheter des électeurs mais
c'est certain que c'est une mesure qui
est électoraliste et puis on se cache
pas qu'on était à six mois des élections
donc sa teinte le budget puis bon
monsieur legault est pas différent des
autres partis politiques
c'est pas comme s'ils étaient seuls à
faire ça on a vu justin trudeau faire la
même chose là avant les dernières
élections à langoat du chèque par hasard
comme ça avant dès avant les élections
c'est une stratégie qui est qui est
plutôt répandue et à laquelle il est
difficile de résister et on sait que
tout le monde était heureux mais en même
temps il faut comprendre qu'on combat
pas l'inflation en ajoutant de l'argent
insiste m au contraire ça va ça va avoir
des effets néfastes on savait que si on
rajoute de l'argent c'est comme si on
arrose un incendie avec les sens ça va
savoir à lang a
exacerbé l'inflation donc contrer
l'inflation moi j'étais d'accord et j'ai
trouvé que les mesures qui ont été
adoptées dans le mini budget l'automne
dernier qui était ciblé sur les moins
nantis était logique parce que ces
genres il faut comprendre me consacre
les deux tiers de leur budget
pratiquement à des dépenses essentielles
le transport le logement l'épicerie
alors que les gens plus fortunés c'est
seulement quand donc pourquoi donner une
famille par exemple les deux parents
gagnent juste un peu moins de 100 à 1000
les deux enfants sont agencés genre
après avoir chacun les 4 personnes 500
d'avoir deux mille dollars dans une
famille parce que les jeunes de plus de
18 ans ayant droit aussi ça fait
beaucoup d'argent alors qu'une mère
monoparentale avec deux enfants mineurs
elle va avoir cinq cents dollars même si
et gagnent seulement
gens ne rien donner plus stéphanie à ce
canon beaucoup besoin ben je pense que
ça a été plus logique de six blessés
pèsent sur les plus démunis christian
sur cette opération 500 dollars je suis
d'accord avec stéphanie franchement le
la classe moyenne à un couple qui fait
200 à 1000 $ parce que c'est ça la
classe moyenne c'est clair qu'on est
dans l'électoralisme mais si vous me
permettez patrice je devrais pas répéter
ce qui a été dit depuis une journée
seulement faire un commentaire qui est
peut-être plus identitaire et
sociétaires en fait moi ce qui me frappe
c'est que depuis hier on nous dit qu'on
est riche les québécois c'est
merveilleux vraiment on donne même de
l'argent du monde qui on n'a pas
vraiment besoin on nous dit que
d'économie à performer plus que dans le
reste du canada on n'est pas habitué à
ça supplie identitaire ça nous fait un
velours et moi ça m'inquiète un peu que
ce soit le seul message parce que je
trouve qu'au québec le le réflexe
spontané quand tu as des problèmes on
dit on va avoir plus d'argent on va voir
plus de financement on veut avoir plus
de ressources on n'a pas le réflexe de
changer les façons de faire je trouve
que c'est un message qui est insidieux
parce que plus mon âge dans l'argent
puis qu'on érige pourquoi changeraient
ton les façons de faire là on nous dit
qu'on va réformer le système de santé
faudrait pas que ce soit juste plus de
cash dans un système de relève compris
ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est un
merveilleux c'est là qu'on est riche la
violence et les autres mais incitatif à
changer nos façons de voir je vous
relancez là dessus parce qu'on posait la
question je posais la question me nice
hier la santé recevra 9 milliards de
plus pour les cinq prochaines années
c'est une augmentation de 6,3 pour cent
du budget de la santé alors la
refondation est d'autant plus importante
christian ce que vous dites c'est pour
que ça marche mieux
juste un second un commentaire qui va
m'attirer des courriels haineux je veux
c est ce que moi je ne pensais quand
même pour le prêt ministre philippe
couillard et son ministre des finances
l'état au c'est quand même eux qui ont
enclenché la nouvelle ère dont on
profite où on nous rétablit les finances
publiques chez qui on était très très
critiquée aujourd'hui j'ai pensé un peu
à eux parce que je sais que c'est pas
très à la mode de sonia les libéraux je
pense que vous allez voir tant de
courriels pour cela on a déjà vu pire
christian
sur québec martin ça c'était intéressant
on va voir les propos d'éric caire qui a
attaqué mais vraiment façon assez direct
le maire de québec entend vous allez
nous enlever des voix votre amour et ça
fonctionne pas la circulation va
augmenter on va coûter monsieur caire
réponse de monsieur marc charbon revient
le maire de québec dit qu'il veut pas
faire une guerre à l'automobile qu'il le
prouve et qu'ils arrêtent de
polluer l'existence des conducteurs avec
des projets comme ça suppose une vision
d'avenir qui fait qu'on n'est pas là
pour nous on n'est pas là pour une
élection on n'est pas là pour gagner en
compter une circonscription parce qu'on
a pas de x y ou z mais parce qu'on fait
notre travail en pensant aux gens pour
qui on le fait pour les générations qui
suivent pour celles et ceux qu'on veut
bâtir une ville et ceux à qui on veut
laisser quelque chose qui va avoir
encore du sens
le caire s'est excusé on va voir le
twizy j'allais trop loin ce matin
charlie trop loin du style même si j'ai
un désaccord avec le maire monsieur
marchand quant au tramway il ya une
personne de ville et une personne de
bonne foi et cetera donc il a voulu
calmer le jeu martin il ya deux visions
qui s'affrontent à québec puis on voit
que la cac en traits d'un côté et puis
on veut pas être perçu comme étant de
l'autre ouais en fait il ya l'enjeu et
le contexte l'enjeu c'est que le maire
de québec veut avoir son tramway pour la
ville de québec a fait des déclarations
publiques là dessus en disant c'est pas
pour les banlieues c'est pour les gens
de québec la vision du gouvernement et
les plus globale c'est à dire on appelle
sol le réseau express de québec on veut
avoir le tramway à québec et le
troisième lien c'est un va pas sans
l'autre et on trouve à québec que le
maire de québec ne se mouille pas sur le
troisième vient alors qu'il ya eu quand
même plusieurs réunions le gouvernement
travaille à un nouveau projet du
troisième bien un peu plus économique
et on voudrait qu'ils en parlent
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs dans son point de
presse il n'y a pas parlé du troisième
mais alors ça c'est l'enjeu le contexte
c'est que monsieur marchand est élu
depuis six mois et son étoile brille ça
va très bien pour lui il est influent
mais il tient son bout alors que
monsieur legault lui 120 élections dans
six mois c'est difficile pour ces
députés à québec et dans les banlieues
il tient son troisième duel mais je
dirais qu'il voire avant s'il exactement
alors le caucus de québec et nerveux là
alors c'est s'explique un peu là la
sortie de directeur très enflammée mais
il y en a d'autres en caucus lucky qui
sont mécontents de la situation due aux
électeurs nos pauvres hiver on est de
votre côté les auteurs ont les ailes ne
voulez-vous pas commenté et christian où
ses fans est bien obligé parce que je
suis je vais t'apprendre cette chose
mais moi j'ai vécu 24 ans québec dont
québec québec québec quelle culture
politique spécifique ce qui me frappe en
fait le ton l'émotion c'est un autre
monde eric dumain on sait que c'est là
qu'il a du succès donc le québec c'est
pas juste montréal et les régions c'est
aussi québec québec québec sont vraiment
spécifique quand on peut pas se tromper
le temps est fascinant fait vers gros
journée oui c'est fascinant le mystère
québec comme on dit hier cette alliance
plc npd a fait réagir aujourd'hui
monsieur legault qu'était attention là
si vous venez vous gérer le système de
santé ça va aller mal on dit qu il va y
avoir une affrontements pochette le
québec là avec toutes les provinces
entre autres avec l'ontario ce pauvre
est que d'oxford en ontario va accepter
que ce soit justin trudeau qui dise
comment on administre le budget de la
santé il ya un front commun très fort
des provinces pour dire la santé c'est
un champ de compétence des provinces
sont les provinces sont les mieux
classés pour choisi mais l'on ne deux
parties très centralisateur le parti
libéral du canada et le npd qui veulent
imposer sa à l'ensemble des provinces je
pense qu'ils vont frapper un noeud
moi je pense que québec et ottawa
s'entend et québécois qui gagne nous de
notre côté on veut toujours s'entendre
mais nous ce que l'on veut c'est que la
brique les provinces là dessus c'est
quelque chose d'important j'étais chez
le dentiste sa semaine dernière je suis
pas aussi à lire le billet remangaï zoo
mais ça coûte cher c'est que j'avais des
familles qui promeut les moyens puis
soit que sa dette ou des fois il vaut
pour
ces familles grâce avec vous est-ce
qu'ils vont frapper un nul comme dit
monsieur legault et je pense
qu'effectivement il ya quand même des
deux partis fédéraux et qu'ils sont
plutôt centralisateur et monsieur
monsieur legault lui qui veut pas avoir
d' ingérence que personne qui lit dans
ses plates bandes conporec donc
peut-être que dans le fond pour lui
c'est une bonne chose parce que
c'est toujours bien d'avoir un ennemi
pour avec qui se battent parce que ça il
va pouvoir défendre les intérêts des
québécois du crédit et elle avait des
élections c'est peut-être pas une si
mauvaise chose que ça par contre on
souhaite vraiment que le fédéral envoie
des transferts en santé se demande de
monsieur le mou des provinces à laquelle
monsieur trudeau a pas encore vraiment
donné suite les négociations temps c'est
pas c'est pas du luxe dont on a besoin
de cet argent là pour sortir la pandémie
les implants qui va être annoncés très
bientôt là à québec pour
restructurer le réseau de la santé 7 s
et au provincial de l'oeuf un espoir
de venir midi martine c'est très clair
et monsieur legault a voulu dire aussi
j'veux pas tout seul tu ford est là
aussi puis on va on se lâchera pas cette
fois ci c'est le principal grief de
monsieur legault et d'autres provinces à
l'égard du premier ministre trudeau
c'est l'ingérence dans les champs de
compétence il a passé presque l'ensemble
du mandat à se défendre à ce niveau là
alors quand j'ai vu cette alliance là il
n'y avait ni un ni deux il ya dit je
vais je vais tout de suite mettre mon
poing sur la table pour que tout le
monde sache où je me place
l'enjeu de l'assurance dentaire ça va
être assez intéressant parce que c'est
imminent si je comprends bien les
annonces devrait se faire lors du
prochain peut-être prochain budget
fédéral
ici à québec qui ça fait partie des
discussions et je me suis remémoré
une anecdote parce que lors de
l'élection de 2018 c'était dans le
programme électoral de la de québec
solidaire dans fait même dans la
plateforme électorale de québec
solidaire une assurance dentaire la cac
avait jonglé avec cette idée là on
m'avait raconté ce au début du mandat
qu'on avait jonglé avec l'idée mais
quand québec solidaire est arrivé avec
cette idée là on peut me saute sur la
glace mais c'est quand même un programme
l'idée fait son chemin alors peut-être
que la caq a envie d'avoir de proposer
ce genre de avec trois grammes mais
l'oeil voudrait peut-être pas se faire
voler son punch et s'assurer que
l'argent et tu pourras la dépense et
comme il veut et comme il l'entend avoir
le chèque le droit de retrait avec
compensation christian dufour ça vous
rappelle ses batailles éternelle de
champ de compétence vous lisez dans mes
pensées dans une autre vie j'ai
travaillé comme conseiller en relations
fédérales provinciales plus ça change
plus c'est pareil sauf que monsieur
legault raison de s'en faire parce que
le npd est encore plus centralisateur
historiquement les libéraux qui en même
temps ça fait un peu son affaire sur une
année électorale et puis quelle
merveilleuse adversaire que d'avoir à
ottawa cette issue peut revenir quand
j'ai pris le parti de commenter ça moi
j'assume revenue totalement pour être
membre de cette alliance là entre les
libéraux et le npd j'ai trouvé que cette
part est quelque chose de profondément
honteux l'adage monsieur singh d'hinges
possible de se regarder dans le miroir
parce que la dernière élection le
l'enjeu principal on le sait c'est un
monsieur trudeau était minoritaire puis
voulait devenir majoritaire et les
calaisiens ont décidé de réélire un
gouvernement minoritaire
le six mois après on se retrouve avec
une entente formelle entre les deux
parties c'est un précédent n'est pas
vrai que ça si ça c'est déjà pas assez
de la même façon les jo d entente avant
l'élection des attentes est une entente
formelle après l'élection trudeau le oui
ça ressemble à sion un peu amer n'y
avait pas d'entente signé il n'y avait
pas d'entendre fort mais moi je trouve
que c'est vraiment pas respecté le
mandat que les électeurs ont donné au
gouvernement ces deux là monsieur 5 puis
monsieur trudeau qui font la morale à
tout le monde tout le temps là ils
devraient avoir honte parce qu'il
respecte pas le mandat que les canadiens
auront donné puis tant qu'à faire
pourquoi ils font pas un vrai
gouvernement de coalition avec des
milliers npd au mois ce serait plus
frein oui mais sur monsieur singh répond
à ce que vous dites que je vais attendre
nos deux camarades que le but est plus
important il est dit je suis pragmatique
il y aura une assurance dentaire pour
les 12 ans et moins d'abord pour les 18
ans et moins ensuite puis bon cc on sait
cartographier et que c'est plus
important que tout le reste ceux ci
stéphanie êtes vous d'accord
oui on est tous le monde pour pour la
tarte aux pommes lundi mais c'est sûr
que oui et on dira pas qu'un plan pour
couvrir les gens qui ont besoin de soins
dentaires ou une mauvaise chose moi ce
qui m'inquiète un peu plus puis je suis
quand même un peu d'accord mais que
christian dit le que ça change la donne
par rapport à ce que les ce que les
électeurs avaient avait mis dans la
boîte aux dernières élections mais voici
vous préoccupe c'est d'un point de vue
financier et les toutes les fois où les
néo les néo démocrates se sont alliés
aux libéraux
mais c'est bien il s'entend mais ils
s'entendent pour toutes les mesures des
deux plateformes et que ça coûte cher et
donc les libéraux ont déjà dépensé
énormément d'argent pour lutter contre
la pandémie moi je veux bien programme
l'un pour les dents et puis on a aussi
plaidé que ça prendrait plus de dépenses
du côté militaire parce qu'on se rend
compte que on a du chemin à rattraper
puis il ya une guerre donc tout cela est
bel et bon mais à la fin ça fait
beaucoup de priorités et
la facture au bout de la ligne et ceux
qui ont des craintes ce qu'avait d'écrin
martin que déjà le gouvernement de
monsieur trudeau seules dépenses et trop
bas imaginer là ils ont encore plus de
grain et il va y avoir des divisions
très certainement
dans le caucus libéral en tout cas parce
que quand même les canadiens ont pas
voter s'ils avaient voulu avoir le
programme du npd ils auraient voté pour
monsieur signe si au québec il presque
absent alors c'est sûr qu'il va y avoir
des divisions non seulement sur la
facture mais aussi sur la façon dont on
va présenter les différents projets
parce que les canadiens aux pauvreté
pour sa très bien combien nous reste de
ta on a un très court tour de table sur
une question très simple je commence
avec vous martine rapidement est-ce
qu'on a des confiné à trouver parce que
là les gens pourront pas mettre les
freins martin il ya aucun appétit à
québec pour confiner davantage pour
ajouter des mesures sanitaires c'est
clair on veut pas parler de ça c'est
fini
on est allé rapidement le et riscle il
reste le masque et où je pense qu'il
faut il faut être prudent il n'y a pas
de raison le d'aller au devant et
attendons de voir ce que ça donne et
cartes n'essayons pas de télégraphie on
a vu ce que ça donnait canton de 7 mai
voir un trop long terme parfois nous
faisait tous marcher sur la fin
christian pour le bilan le bilan de
monsieur boileau josu était quand même
rassurant pu heureusement parce que
depuis la guerre en ukraine et dans
autre chose on est dans un autre
paradigme je rentre on peut recommander
des choses aux québécois mais ça
passerait très très difficilement des
mesures coercitives c'est plus comme
c'était la pandémie l'apocalypse c'est
la guerre en ukraine la peur du
nucléaire c'est plus la pandémie merci à
vous trois très disciplinés très
intéressant merci au revoir je n'avais
pas de courriels sur christian jeu en
tout cas pour pas là dessus merci à lui
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh